[Music]
good evening everyone welcome to our
playback pro night and tonight we have a
flam well I don't know if he is
technically considered flamboyant but I
literally like him
sweet ler great a very great player with
that eight times Russian champion he is
one Russian championship more than
anybody anyone else several times
playing the candidates graduates always
in World Cup and whenever I see it when
I was in one World Cup and I've seen him
a couple of Olympians and it seems as if
he's very nervous during game or maybe
he is but somehow in those Rapids and
[Music]
okay in those Rapids and and plates and
all these critical moments he can
prevail he can maintain his nerve and
overcome overcome his opponents he won
one World Cup got to the final in 2015
and we all loved his commentaries and
videos so let's look at the games I
picked from but what why I picked see
they were fun one thing was that
Jonathan recommended so I considered but
the second reason was the second part is
that he is one of the modern James who
his his career took off in 1990s so the
time that you if you would mention five
names will be on on Kasparov okay carpet
to the mid-1990s and then later came
kramnik off of course also not later
kramnik and then maybe once we can name
to polish and sheriff joined it he
started winning tournaments and he was
younger than them so and then in 2001
just moved to you know a lot of
ingenious computer analysis he still was
on top of it so he is always with all
his evolution of chess in the past 28
years so that was always there
and he's been an elite player if I would
say from 1996 or 71 or maybe five his
first Russian championship
he's been there among the elite till now
before I start talking before I start
showing you the game the first one I
picked which is from the early years of
his career for Turiaf in 1997 sorry
similar game against three from 1997 I
like to mention a couple of points maybe
more than a couple of points about his
style well similar is a great opening
expert with very very deep and
interesting ideas his understanding of
dynamic is really great and I would
classify him as a player single optical
power well this is my personal opinion
some others made me think differently
and one thing I really like about this
he's just I'll talk about the other
things that is good about his style
later but I one thing also very very
very interested and interesting about
his style is he can be a very devious
similar yes yes similar so and we have
one of his in here against tip olive and
I'd like that you know an elite player
of course his technique is fantastic his
understanding of positional chess and he
is a very complete player but I like
this you know resilience and being
cunning in the top tier chess player I
just like it so another reason to pick
sweetly so this game from 1997 against
Terry have a very solid player so over
the years
sweet learn a little shift it is a style
he was exclusive an e4 player with a
very broad and sharp repertoire and now
there's so much other players help he
also plays d4 and
both efore then of course things again
have changed from 1990's we just know
deeply one one opening
say one opening but he would be an
expert in either an e for player or a
default layer' now players played both
844 balls okay talking enough let's look
at this game
Scandinavian so the EF goes for this
line 93 and actually no it's not that
bad just just to mention recently
Carlsen in this year's why can't he was
playing against ID bond from India and I
had actually the game here Saudi for
Bishop g4 h3 wish-a-wish 5 this is
actually the game here called some
played Bishop e2 and although computer
claimed some edge and Carlson is known
to be a great grinder it gradually
fizzled out his advantage fizzled out on
the game internet draw so I can show you
a few more moves even got the pair of
bishop looks very very nice but at the
end of this candidate intro so although
it may sound you know your tales talked
about a Scandinavian is a second hand
opening and not an elite GM opening but
it has its own merits so let's see how
soother handle this Euler went c4 this
is youngster their attack in 1997 so it
is risky well I want to that's risky but
plays the most principled let's say nice
e3e 5
okay the fight starts already I don't
think at that time the theory of this
opening was that developed so probably
at this moment the players or maybe a
month later the players were on their
own doesn't look correct to me five
right what do you think doesn't look
correct
okay now g4 that's that's the move but
then I have this one he takes d4 and now
Knight takes d4 now I'm going to win a
very valuable tempo and move like c5
loses - this is just loses the Queen e2
check I don't know if I analyze this
position by 95 it just looks very bad so
now I got a job back what is ahead in
development do we do we have an
agreement on that or not
why is that its first of all it's first
of why to move and what is closer to
castle them black why is that that's
also an important question why do I
believe why do we believe that what is a
heading development and can castle off
faster than black sooner than black
close most importantly you have a very
strong threat this moment this moment
that would get you way ahead and
development so basically the issue with
development its importance was solved by
Murphy he was the first one who I
wouldn't say fully but he understood the
open positions he understood if I have
active pieces if I'm controlling the
important files diagonals and ranks and
I'm placing my pieces on active squares
then things should work so he basically
deciphered the open positions
requirements so you set open position do
we agree on that
all the pawns in the center have been
exchanged so we're doing with the total
open position so every threat and every
temple you get ahead could have immense
effect on the course of the game so can
we bring a very important temple here
how much the simple Bishop g2 I am ready
to castle and I'm taking that pawn b7
right as simple as that so we go c6 and
now Castle ok suddenly now we have such
a lead in development right yeah black
plays Bishop e7 black is ready to castle
if you leave him to him to himself and
try to play b3 Bishop b2 like houses 97
and actually we'll be left with way too
overly pushed pawns and we have to deal
with our weaknesses that so it's either
Now or Never
that means what shall we do let me give
you a few minutes maybe thank you
let's see what what sooner did similar
played f4 first Cephas I have considered
c5 and this this actually wins so I
think he played c5 I think why this is
our voices at four I think he played C
plate he plays c5
I think what's that I just grabbed it I
think I just take tonight
well the point is that is the attack I
think he played c5 with the game but let
me check the notation just a second okay
I'm sure I'm sure just yes c4 okay this
is my analysis it's I say that and of
course I took some of the car similars
analysis but I add my own line this c5
is actually more accurate because
because of this check but therefore
nevertheless now I'm flirting to win the
bishop and h-65
okay now that bishop is bad yeah but now
remember we have given up this diagonal
and this can become vulnerable so we
have to take measures immediately now
can argue I'm going to give you guys
five minutes and if you find the idea
you will be very pleased now I just take
the policy for our castle
a very sharp one actually
yes I just take well you know you give
you give we Bishop you give life to my
bishop on it seven now remember as black
I don't need to put my knight on b8 on
these seven necessarily which gives you
some tactics I can just put it on a six
so I have six I can take you give a
check Kings goes King goes to f8 a
bishop on f6 will defend the Queen and
d8 and after the 96-95 I'm kind of okay
it's not better
and then the King goes to g8 Bishop g6
King comes to g7 so if you go here I'm
not going to give any line but I may be
able after it some checks you can go see
if this is the way I can actually know
castle I can take the pawn on c4 I can
just castle you need a threat but there
is not that idea of 96 in some line
could work that that's the hint
exactly
if text and then we're happy we should
be thrilled
and then mission goes to F to Queen
Queen to d3 or something like a not
develop yep because now I cannot move
the bishop on his seventh you see that
so but here black made a huge mistake by
going back to these g7 now g5 not not g5
now black for the now g5 w scram now if
I go H Tech's g5 I cannot is 6 g 5 Hz is
that I open this tag on for obviously
just this ends this ends nasty and if it
takes
and if 9 f6 I don't know if I should
take first where I just played g7 and if
I go here obviously what happens here
just to check with you know check me she
yeah beautiful and yeah this is this is
young suitable Ursa the game is
fantastic Castle you know how do we
continue here so one thing I like about
super sharp style and in his in his
earlier years as a up-and-coming maybe
future contender he never got a shot at
becoming an old champion he even if I
could get close to fight for it
unfortunately for him but he was very
sharp and he would never lose momentum
that was that's what I really liked
about him is like in that sense he was
very much like as part of he doesn't
lose momentum it was going so now he
lose momentum keep going what's the move
what's next move
g6 why not because why because I have
this move oh wait a second now by has
two parts and it's is it our our attack
fizzled out did did he miss something
did-did-did us we miss something here so
because after all these exchanges let me
go over it again the Sultan saw force so
96 Queen goes to ca I take the rook you
take check I have to move my king -
obviously h1 I mean I don't know if
computer should ever King gets to in
some fantastic lines but human nature I
don't run into check I never my king to
check so King each one there F takes G 6
bishop g6
did he miss something
what is still ahead in development yes
that's it ha see he doesn't give rest I
love this game he doesn't give even one
move rest to black now he's up material
he's only he's taking back one of the
pawns right and no black is exposed what
can I do the only move is to play 95
right G takes it six losses - thank you
sir thank you so much taking 25 can get
7
I think Black has only one defender
right what what I put here is that after
after rook f6 because now Queen e8
simply runs into Luke takes g6 this is
simple another the Queen takes them yeah
and if take 95 then what do we do here
our Queens hanging well I think we can
just publish it before ah that doesn't
work no no if you take I was I was going
to do this still running right but I
think it plays
Queenie's 26 better it likes it better
that way hi Rocky 6 o CN Jesus folio I
have analyzed this I have looked at the
olives because but I was putting all the
ends in lines I would I'm like I have to
think yeah what was that
so can I get to that chess no matter in
what class you're going to not analyze
your games with engine do not try to use
engine until you reach a certain level
you're trying to learn open so deep that
unity engines really
so okay this this was obvious bishop
with six played 95 so tempo again attack
the knife we should respect to be chef
job Specter for attacking the knight so
now we are open material up material we
have an attack and black has not still
finished its development 94 I'm
eyeballing going to eyeballing going to
d6 Knight to g5 this check on b3 is very
nasty it all makes sense right oh not
there in there knight can be three check
okay now that palm b7 looks very yummy
if I go if I go pee shiver seven I think
we can grab that or maybe no that does
actually look yummy I want to go here if
I go P shape of seven I can just go
Queen g3 is that what happened ah with
that queen of seven now the Queen
actually covers and then covers the King
some battery along with G file and the
FF file is really looking bad for black
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes and
then okay this is not part of my lecture
but I just to show you the few next
moves their knowledge 5 Queen g5 full of
the genetics f4 runs of the Queen takes
e5 and that's that night on the forest
paint like that I'll be eliminated so 93
but should be 527 takes Queen takes
Queen f7 check and there we go 5 done
nicely done but okay that for players of
Sweden air level this is just like a
mating one it just comes naturally ok so
from the things we mention about Street
there what did we see in this game
mm-hmm good hmm he's he has a very good
sense of dynamic and the motion you know
the momentum he has a very good sense of
momentum like I can speak for myself
I understand dynamics I think to a good
extent for a GM level but I have problem
of the sense of momentum I don't know
how fast I have to go I see that Oh
things are coming but I don't know how
fast I have to watch do I need to make a
sacrifice well and sometimes I can't
figure it that but a lot of time I have
I have trouble with so I tried to take
the safer choice that's me and his sense
of momentum II just I can't praise it
really I can appreciate it because he
knows that ah I'm going to sway and
that's that's the trend I have to go he
has that sense this is very important so
we cannot see everything or not machines
but that sense that feeling that I can
see it sound exactly like child but he
also had that as part of mentioning one
of his interviews that tal was like ah
maybe it was in his book there my great
predecessors that tall was not like
exactly a person who can capture like a
maniac and see all the lines but he had
this feeling that he had this tall
moment that everything would fall in
place angry just know I him his eyes
would glitter that is ah this is it and
he would see everything is working out
and then he would see all the variations
and everything so I don't know what we
can called sort of an intuition for
dynamics yeah I see it in sooner and I
as a Grand Master who is not this is
tower I'm not that good at this new
style of chess I can really appreciate
and learn a lot from it okay next game
so next game so next game let me see I
want to show the share of game but this
is very similar and in terms of style so
I take a break from it for now I want to
show a little bit a bit of more mature
similar and then we go back so this is a
game from Bundesliga 2010 against
machiya who is now coach of the utrgv at
UNICEF takes us through grande they want
the final four this year
so and he also had as a very great
resume he was once a European champion
so that speaks for being a strong player
so much yes so this is the this is a new
trend in all I was I was a new but is
the most dominant trend in caro-kann in
top level almost everyone plays d5
advanced caro-kann and Bishop III I
don't think this is the main trend
neither 3b should be too used is the one
that they usually play but this is
nevertheless a playable move I've seen
this one and then right here usually
nowadays they do 9 f3 is six Bishop b2
and they first developed at night I
don't know why they keep the bishop in
and then and then play Bishop III if
they need to
that's the current trend that's the the
hot topic in advanced cleric on debates
so we should be 3 the idea is that
probably I don't want to block my Bishop
before I did mine item d3 let's see what
happens now this this Knight 97 should
be to Bishop g6
speaking of pair of bishop mileage for
so
nowadays that you see through their not
marvelous as you can see this game has
been played 13 years after the first
game I showed you and he has of course
this is the most principal continuation
still here he always go he still goes
for the most principled continued
Shanina get in a position and he he
likes to get a technical position now
you see this is a bit more solid I'm
thinking I'm getting my pair of bishop
then I've denied their Knight goes to a3
I'd like to have two bishops and see if
I I think this is a huge mistake
actually because after c3 Knight c6 I
still think neither five should be
played I should not just give up my to
bishops that's simply I consider this
way better for wife it's sure that the
pawn structure is similar to advanced
French now where the problem is the
bishop on c8 and now we don't have the
bishop on c8 but we have a little bit of
peaky and pawn structure which gives us
a hook here I call this a hook that can
be exploited like this I'll see how that
will happen
so I believe this is much better for
white but okay mochi I had different
opinion about this there should be seven
castle castle Bishop d3 right I'm
improving I'm planning to where's my
advantage on the kingside black doesn't
have enough defenders right the knight
on c6 is far from different here and
where I have more space the pony 5 gives
me more space on the kingside obviously
I'm going after the kingdom or is solid
rock c8 and and and the serious
technical player really I really
appreciated what does what did he do
here think I actually think that the
right move was a three more accurate
but what do you think he did h4 exactly
but a three just to avoid any problem
with c64 and then later on doing it g3
h4 King G - Rakesh 100 H 5 going after
the h5
so night before now we have a little bit
of problem with our pieces it's not big
deal but one piece should stay on the
board which is what our Queen we need
our queen for the attack it's a queen in
six I have to go back windy one Queen
see 691 is force well we don't care
about the are rich pan do we I mean we
we want to just play try to open the
file anyways so there's no problem he he
gets his position the pieces are in
place now here I don't know anytime
pressure or something else here he
didn't go for the most principled world
for the winning line basically yep why
he's winning actually you need a little
calculation here it cannot only be
solved intuitively I'll give you a few
minutes maybe to to think a little bit
night 2p4 where's my attack on the
kingside right everybody
toward the Kings Island I take a for
right well I you know and sometimes in
time pressure we can see things maybe he
was afraid of this move but this doesn't
work because we just got Queen h3 and
made his comic well we tacked the Queen
just the Queen can move right by
attacking it's just you don't get what
you want but neither for now I'm trying
to exploit this
oops these pawns why doesn't make okay
these are all weaknesses and now my
Livescribe bishop comes into life with
the immense mod immense power so neither
fate and now was the winning way I don't
know if he might not have seen it or he
may have become complacent it can happen
to everyone
Bishop d3 Queen there and then just
rotate 7 destroy it and then our 96 or
King at 7 I mean doesn't matter really
who comes here Queen comes and then made
his following so I don't know what
happened to suit Larry but he didn't go
for this one and he got to some trouble
I did not know he he started making
mistakes and then suddenly it turns out
that pops it's not clear now here are
thing to learn from sooner he domain
well I wouldn't say compose but he
managed to maintain the pressure and
keep on playing let's see what he found
here Bishop d3 very strong move if I
take then look at fall and then take on
g7 checkmate this doesn't work this is
this leads to mate
so much it plays very good correctly so
now he's down the piece but okay first
of all he has enough compensation blacks
nights are awkward he has how many pawns
does he have any problem actually here's
one pound for a sacrifice piece he will
win the second point on g6 and if it's a
third one probably on b7 but it's not
winning anymore
Bishop takes c6 9 f7 rook takes b7 and
here it was Machias only chance to save
the game night at 6
look h4 and okay it and surprisingly
well of course when you run Houdini or
ASM or or a stock fish or sugar or all
of these new engines are on Komodo it's
easy to sit there and have some tea like
I have now and say ok he could save it
over the board with the time pressure is
very difficult but this was his only
chance to and hardly hard to believe but
if I can improve now
then I comes to g5 back to f7 back to h7
back to of seven like a move like rookie
7 runs into night effect for example so
suddenly the night's become handy
by the way Knight is an attacking piece
or defensive piece defensive it's good
to use them for defense they are very
good they have because they sit close to
the king or something in the back there
and then just controlling many scores a
bishop on f8 controls how many scores
nearby let's say if I have a bishop on
f82 scores yeah but when you have an
item FN equals 4
so look at 498 check there and this
nobody can improve so here comes the
mistake there and worked except 87 now I
have I have three points right no four
three three one oh wow okay that to that
moment it so at that point there was no
there was no pieces there was no pause
he right I have to work on my car I have
to work on my counting yeah yeah because
he sacked eh ma forgot that 22 countries
he sacked eh ma one second I forgot that
so now yes three he has a dominant
Bishop on g6 and he has two pounds
running and then the rest he gradually
but surely and versus at the antigen
this is also very nice to learn from
Bishop of seven-night of similar care
for when you have pawns your opponent
has night or night or any minor piece
trade the rooks looks look look a minor
piece are good defenders together I can
stop pawns from being pushed c5 okay 398
takes takes let's roll check there b5 no
time to waste
okay
do we just promote now because if it
from more take sticks and I have King f5
you see that's a very valuable temple
actually plays first g4 but I was
thinking okay it is equal to good
probably locate seven you take on c6 and
take on e6 but he wanted to kill the
counter play so you just did that look
at 7:38 you need this way and now they
said two points up and game it's it's
say to positive okay
and this is a beautiful King g6 and then
I cannot touch the pawn on e6 it's going
to be promoted and that's it
nice fun right okay we go back and we
talked about sooner being a swindle
swindler so look at his swindle against
against the pull of this game is from
2004 so this is called the English
attack and now is in this line there's
there's a tribe it should be seven they
play a lot of things nowadays but not
the way through there with elegy for
they don't play the deadly G for anymore
this is the from the art of fashion
these days delay the last game in it is
was in 2011 and it wasn't among it
wasn't between two very strong players
actually and they were just a handful of
games in this position I think this
early G pawn push because the amount
goes to h5 and first of all black
doesn't play just Knight b6 minute work
anymore
which actually which he can because
white only push to g4 so he was
threatening to play the other reason is
that this night if you've just led
tonight on that five too early he's
black a lot of mojo choices so Queen d2
Castle and then committing the g4 just
committing to g4 g5 is more common these
days so Queen d2 Bishop e7 Castle there
Rock Jiwon obviously I don't want to
pledge for to give away g3 square Ho Chi
Hwan because I I need to move my queen
to get it here or at least somewhere I
mean I could have D file because it's
not c4 is coming and then to do that I
cannot let the chief I've found just
loose and here comes now of the rook
takes c3 qualify the time what was at
the top of his game and he played the
sacrifice so Bishop takes b6 Bishop
takes g5 King be one is forced well
ninety two runs and a bishop is fourth
can be won now the queen is hanging the
Queen stuck to the bishop they look on
see through sighing did he miss
something no he has a counter-attack
research for now the bishop f2 attacks
the rukon g3 so I put some of my rope to
g3 because Bishop takes the yeah if I
take here this this is bad everything is
falling plus black like he's in time to
grab the right material black is in time
so g3 takes takes rook back to c7 and
that's the problem after this night well
okay now actually we can say one thing
sweeter or surprised and he got caught
in the opening by surprise so black is
better White has mere compensation for
the pot but let's see how he makes the
most out of what he can get nice if I
like a lot of great players and
especially in dynamic situations sooner
manage to make the most amount of
practical problems for his opponent
let's see what happens here 95.7 takes
takes takes and the ship h3 okay all
these exchanges are force let's do it
again machine which three hardly enough
compensation
okee 8 now octi 3 I'm thinking about
putting my rope on c3 maybe maybe
quantity 2 attacking the pawn on d6
right back there and I'm preparing d5
now what more would cause most amount of
practical problem for black in this
position
and similar found it well that's coming
but what about Queen h7 if I wait
black will gradually convert so I need
to I need to make the water a bit muddy
too to be able to fish something well
that's actually Persian expression make
the waters muddy to fish so the file
would have done it rook p3 rocky 7 and
black is okay but the polyp is a lil bit
of brush because if you place d5 and
take thick and then before it suddenly
starts to run run and the game is over
and the Queen and a7 doesn't do anything
really cook c3 Queen d7 going back to b6
now it's getting annoying I wanna play
Luka c7
okie seven look back to d3 if I was
getting I mean black is preparing to
play d5 and it's gonna be pretty
annoying because II d5 you know this
guys are perfect perfect for a fork
right so we better move it
so they're t5 85-95
quinn drops back Queen to b5 strong love
very strong move probably nowadays and
the modern analysis should show that
white has to take on before and hope for
the best which is probably wouldn't be
enough I think tip-off had it he was he
was in control and he was trying to win
the game he was close to win the game so
taking is a possibility but he plays the
Queen d6 again the most practical this
creates the most amount of practical
problems for black keeping the Queen on
the board Knight back to be tonight goes
to B for look T to remember this is
score is still controlled by the sky so
actually the way
so they're p3 Queen C 3 so Quincy 4 is
attacking the pawn I to black pasta
checkmate right now
oops keep clicking on this thing so I
have to go p3 Queen C 3 F 3 is hanging
now ok we are in trouble right because
we were in trouble we were done a pawn
but it's not that simple right
do we agree on that f4 now again
so here here is the moment that top 11
starts to going wrong it goes astray he
does he takes on g3 it's a big mistake
efore rocky 2 and g6 and black is
winning well good luck finding it so the
point is that if I take on a fortnight
g3 I cannot take on e4 c2 is hanging and
now g3 is hanging there's no a5 there's
no immediate threat and 95 not c3 is a
possibility so I think is everything is
frozen now but it has zero counter
counter play and actually that's the way
you have to play chess when you have
advantage kill all the counter play
before you want to make for the final
strike ok
tipoff things should be maybe she wants
to wrap things up kind of fast goes for
a I said he goes for the hasty
continuation Queen takes g3 Queen takes
b4
26/3 F takes d5 his love upon but now
it's king is weak and white King has no
problem right
give a check he goes Queen III Queen d6
I go such five now that King on f7 is a
bit uncomfortable if I give a check on
f1 life is in deep deep trouble
so I go to p1 I'm preparing to check on
f1 here Queen f2 or Queen e2 either way
is okay
Queen f2 23 okay now I want to play rock
f1 and pin now actually maybe maybe let
me see if we need to would still
maintain the balance I don't remember if
I still the same this is this is
probably balanced Queen if there's a
problem with it after the Queen d3 now
you have one only movie which he missed
he played Queen well after Queen G -
okay fine chicken I have only one one
way to make a draw as black now think
about the shift in the mindset that he
had to endure to follow from being
winning now to fight for a draw and now
after looking front check he made a
mistake like King g8 which loses
immediately I'll show you in a second he
could player King g8 Quincy for their
kuhnian ch4 and not the king runs away
the corner d5 and he's going to be fine
I'm thinking is back to safety but the
material is now balanced so thought was
going to be a draw
the last question of the lecture why to
play and wins and wins to be play and
win so first of all this check to get
seven add another look and I faith the
rookin seven has nowhere to go that's
the problem the King needed to be around
the root to support it when you want to
check they're going back to g5 if coming
back to c5 then the King hunt would lead
to a easy mate
later on Queen d3 and rook so it's for
mate
okay let's go back here when to g5 now
here we have a minus six walk quindi
three check I can up liquin g6 because a
rocket shade so I've got g6 I go back to
these days I just basically I pass them
off but why did I do that so we can have
six
I wanna play rook f6 next month g7 well
this this is because of Queen because of
King g7 I can play Queen b8 and it's
made also recover six is a threat also
this pawn would if I go in let's say
queen bee it early on or something after
check on it a this king could run away
from this is square so this is under way
for the king so this is also important
but provoking g6 the pawn is not on the
way for black so black King succumbs to
his faith while its own army they're on
his way to run away Queen B 8 we need
six 28 and that's it the rook has
nowhere to go
that's the story with similar very nice
comes by him we really appreciate what
he's done for chess so far and the more
he's doing by his lectures and
commentaries and the games is to play
he's a very active and strong player a
little air I don't know if he's top he's
not top ten but he's definitely top 15
our top 16 and he's been top 10 for a
long time so looking forward to see more
of that in future
[Music]